avec 51 étage le 1000 de la gauchetière
cet immeuble en granit gris dont la
superficie atteint près d'un million de
pieds carrés sera le plus élevé de
montréal mais le problème c'est que les
édifices de cette catégorie ont un taux
de vacance de 20% au centre vie en
général un taux de vacance devrait vite
pour les promoteurs comptent attirer des
locataires qui voudront quitter des
locaux plus vétustes actuellement moins
de 30 % de l'espace est occupé
nous avons deux transactions qui chante
presque finalisé qui représente 150
mille pieds carrés et si je suis
optimiste on peut ajouter certainement
50 ou 100 1000 pieds carrés à ça et ça
va doubler le taux d'occupation dans les
prochains 12 mois
et même si aux pieds carrés la location
sera légèrement plus élevé qu'ailleurs
des promoteurs estiment que la plus
value facilitera la location ils vont
bénéficier de la qualité de l'air le
l'emplacement la sécurité d'autres
facteurs militent en faveur de ce
nouveau gratte-ciel en plus d'être relié
directement à la gare intermodale de la
str et simple le nouvel immeuble est
situé juste au dessus de la station de
métro bonaventure
une patinoire intérieure comparable à
celle du rockefeller center de new york
a été aménagé au rez-de-chaussée prévus
pour des représentations artistiques sur
place et pour le patinage libre
on espère que cette patinoire deviendra
un véritable point d'attraction du
centre ville
andré bédard à montvert